now to a troubling story involving one
of america's most successful filmmakers
ryan coogler is best known as the
director of films like black panther and
fruitvale station but in january he
found himself being handcuffed at a bank
of america in atlanta it turns out he
was falsely detained after a teller
mistook him for a bank robber bank of
america has apologized mololenki has
more
minutes after passing a note to a bank
teller asking her to be discreet over a
money withdrawal filmmaker ryan coogler
is approached by police hey sir
i'm in favor
come this way
both of the officers draw their weapons
before placing handcuffs on a surprised
cougar
they were there responding to a possible
bank robbery in progress
coogler was in a bank of america branch
in atlanta where he's been filming the
sequel to black panther
according to the police report coogler
passed a withdrawal slip to a bank
teller with a note written on the back
asking her to be discreet when handing
him twelve thousand dollars in cash
after being cuffed coogler was escorted
to a squad car if you just wrote my name
you'll understand why you should take me
off these cups c-o-o
just put it in google
from the back seat of the squad car
coogler explains to police he was trying
not to call attention to himself in
withdrawing such a large amount of cash
if i don't write down on a note
how much i went out
and now i don't want to run through the
money counter right there at the desk
the whole bank ends up looking at me
coogler was uncuffed minutes later
cbs news reached out to bank of america
and didn't hear back but a spokesperson
told variety we deeply regret that this
incident occurred it never should have
happened and we have apologized to mr
coogler through a rep coogler told cbs
news this situation should never have
happened however bank of america worked
with me and addressed it to my
satisfaction and we have moved on
for cbs mornings
it's unfortunate because i know ryan
kluger was thinking if i give her my
withdrawal slip fill out everything and
just on the back say be discreet because
i don't want everybody in the bank see
me walking out with twelve thousand
dollars for my own safety
i feel like he did everything right he
did everything right and bank of america
says it should not have happened that's
the bottom line can you imagine being
detained for taking out your own money i
cannot but sadly it happens and even if
you're a famous director uh
it can happen to you and we all know why
yeah no doubt about it